blue light cab show we got special
guests in here
we are finally getting the long-awaited
highly anticipated Streamlight four
ladies and Gentlemen let's go live for
you man what up what up what up for Life
simple on the way April 7th the last
time we got I wanted was it the last
time we got the double disc it was like
the double album was that three shrimp
three triple disc it was a Slim Jimmy
sized Swae Lee side and then the group
yeah yeah uh why now for for streamline
four what what made what made the timing
right to give the fans what they've been
asking for man
it's just time
you know what I'm saying it's like so
much time already went by it's like
time you doing I'm passing by you know
I'm saying we got to complete now too
everything's just a line like
business-wise family-wise everything
everybody on the same page he on our
side even with the label everything's
just everybody on the same page it's
like the fans they waited more than long
enough and we appreciate everybody
waiting just sticking by us you know I'm
saying it's just time to put it out you
know say we gotta keep the Legacy going
like it was only the beginning anyway
stream like one two three it's still the
beginning phases you know I'm saying
it's still so much more to the stream
life than we ain't even show the world
you know saying got the chance to show
the world so
it's a perfect timing it's crazy to see
you guys become like oh geez Man legends
in this you know what I'm saying like
yeah the Journey's been so crazy you
guys have had so many uh Peaks and
valleys and we've kind of seen you guys
grow up in front of us like is this the
best music that we're getting from you
guys together so far
I ain't gonna say it's the best because
I feel like the fans judged that but
it's the same approach right we ain't
switching our approach like everything
we did
is got a good response from the people
we ain't switching our approach we just
continuing where we left off so it's
like they know we do they know what type
songs we make they know our cadences a
lot of our Melodies of course we showing
some new sides of us but man it's just
like it's great music it's sticking to
our code sticking to the racial
reformula I like the new album I feel
like it's a lot of growth being sold on
the album our content is a little
different the way that we approach it
the music is a little different you know
what I'm saying and like with all our
albums I feel like they had the people
had to
you know what I'm saying because we
always come different you guys gotta
evolve yeah yeah we always evolve and so
I really like this music you know what
I'm saying I like this album I feel like
it's a great entry into the shrimp life
four I mean it's still the stream life
you know what I'm saying same chain okay
so I know you got you got into a bit of
a spat with my boy Millie's over the
stand sample online because he did a
stand sample it wasn't really a uh no it
was it was nothing like serious yeah it
was very Innocent but yeah yo you guys
got
stand record on this album yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah we put it on there we
just got the clearance man shout out to
everybody
that was because you got to clear that
through uh the Dido chick right man
that's like her record that jump bro
it's not like it's not no easy process
like it's not just one person you know
it's not just Dino
all right
you know what I'm saying but yeah it was
like a process going through the
clearing but you know I'm saying like we
just recently got the clearance and
perfect it's perfect time for the album
like so what kind of record is it are
you like redoing this the the melody or
is it like I'm like is that they doing
some turnips like what kind of record is
it yeah it's like some turn up and it's
like that song I feel like the world
formed that song because
it was like some viral stuff going on
when I sung it and this might put on a
beat and then
the world just been ass playing that
yeah they want that version with the
beat so it's like
the world really produced that song you
feel me so the fan the fans produced it
yeah the fans produced that song so it's
it's just like they wanted it you know
saying we did it just like they wanted
we did a verse Jimmy Jimmy did a verse
we actually had
some some people are interested in
getting on it and it was I think it'd be
a good match but we're gonna see how it
goes but but it got to be done by April
7th so yeah
literally so I replay always gonna play
out but we definitely got that song on
there and yes it's a lot of excitement
around that song so are y'all even being
in Mississippi growing up listening to
Eminem yeah yeah yeah for sure for sure
really no that was definitely my
favorite like it's not like a thing
where I used to like
go on and like I play That Eminem it's
just like our parents that was playing
like VH1 was playing it you know saying
we watch TV the media Atlas we had at
the time for myself
you were rapping was crazy I used to
like the way he wrote I used to try to
rap like him at one point in time in my
life you know what I'm saying what are
those songs now oh no because we got to
hear those I was young I don't even know
how young I was but I definitely would
smell super imminent fan especially when
we had the video where it was like 100
of him oh yeah The Real Slim Shady he
was real controversial yeah he was tight
yeah he was like all over MTV too at the
time it's like you couldn't watch MTV
and not see Eminem on TRL yeah yeah you
know uh congrats to you uh sway because
I want to say I just saw uh the record
with post sunflower is is it the most
streamed song ever all right all a
double a certified yeah the biggest song
number wise for sure that's crazy I
appreciate that too man insane that's
nuts like wow yo give me the background
on how sunflower came to be because it's
really like your record when post has a
verse on it you know what I'm saying
like did you submit that and and post
got on it later like what was that that
process like it was actually
I got you I got you it was actually
crazy man um like we just it was a
normal day you know what I'm saying
cooking up normal week
post um we hit each other up we want to
link do some work Vibe just see where it
goes boom so I pulled up on posters at
electric field you know they was vibing
he was lit turned up like always me and
post always see each other and was
always like good energy you know I'm
saying so we finally got a chance to get
in together and boom Lewis Bell was
there and just his whole team was there
you know so I pulled up like solo
boom he was drinking Bud Lights like a
whole lot of Bud Lights I'm I'm from the
country too I'm from Mississippi so boom
we drinking Bud Light spoon cooking
busted out Bud Light so busting down Bud
Light stacking them up on the table like
this was making like a castle like after
we finished them we just stack them up
like I think we finished like 17 or
something by the time we left the studio
session you drank 17 you no I only drink
like three or four like I was about to
say I don't even know where the other
ones came from like but everybody's just
adding them to the to the castle and
then boom but they played that
particular beat like Lewisville turned
on you know what I'm saying a little
boop bop boom bap look you know I'm
saying little Vibe so Boom turn it on
right to that song and like
that was like the third fourth song I
did of the night yeah the night we was
just going back to back like boom and
then that was it that was like the third
fourth song and then we did a couple
more after that but a couple weeks later
like
um they played it for the makers of the
movie and they ended up loving that song
and then just post put his part on there
he mastered it the movie Spider-Man's
like singing along to it
she had that I see that aspect right
there like that Dynamic that's really
like I think that's the best marketing
like a song can get like something like
that like it's automatically being
presented to this the right demographic
you know I'm saying the kids and they
growing up with the song you know
they're the future of it so they just
streaming as they get older and older I
feel like it's just
it's The Melodies you know it's The
Melodies it feels good it's a bright
song you know what I'm saying it just it
just got a proper look like everything
just lined up perfect with that song you
guys kind of had in my opinion one of
the original like OG like viral moments
in this era of music with the mannequin
challenge I don't think many people are
doing many challenges prior to the
mannequin challenge no nobody would like
black Beatles was like a real moment
like such a great record but like if you
look back to that like give me like
the the origins of how that started
because that was such a crazy I remember
DJing at the club and playing that
everybody in the whole club will stop
it was a time that was a time now I was
just scrolling through Twitter one day
like you know like you said the kids
know they do everything so I seen the
kids doing some little stuff where they
was freezing and I was like yo let's do
this we did it on stage we had this
cameraman shout out to Eric he recorded
it and the funny thing about it
everybody wasn't really still but he
slowed it down to make it look like
everybody was standing still and then it
just it was a crazy video we put it on
the internet it went viral I think I
don't know if I was on tour in Germany
at the time yeah I don't know if I'm
correct yeah because we was on
tournament tour in Germany but I think
it went viral on Thanksgiving or
something like that
every year when they do the oh my gosh
the mannequin challenge went viral on
this day it'd always be Thanksgiving I
just noticed that this year you know
what I'm saying I mean last year you did
what I'm saying but I feel like uh
you're a hell of a father Jimmy I feel
like every time I see you you have your
kids with you I feel like you're always
pushing a stroller I've been seeing you
at concerts backstage you got a little
one with you how's fatherhood changed
you in terms of just like approaching
the music approaching your career just
the way that I take like the way that I
present myself is different you know
what I'm saying I don't want to be
serious but not that I don't want to be
but I'm not I'm just not going to do
certain things you know what I'm saying
I'm still going to be turned I'm still
gonna be lit you don't say I want to be
somebody my kids can can look up to
though you know they did what I'm saying
so that's how I move
I love it man how much uh production is
Mike what is uh Mike Will holding down
on this album a lot yeah it's a lot of
Mike Will production but we got a lot of
other great places too got some got some
slaps on it you got a lot we got like we
got some slaps who else
DJ on the beat so it's a banger Sonny
digital Sunny digital
um business boy for real for real huh
yeah for Real Jesus
um
is it a Pharrell beater speed for real
okay he did he him and Mike will
actually collabed on it yeah so they
came together on that beat yeah
I got a couple of homies one of my
little young homies I found from Texas
his name Jax
Jason yeah DJ DJ shrimp on there yeah DJ
actually made some hard ass beats too so
he on there boom
okay so we know that there might be some
features on the stand record but what
features do we know for sure when this
interview job
next week I can't let you know yet we
could the album bro it's coming out the
week of the hour We're not gonna let the
cat when I tell you we're not gonna let
the cat out of the bed when I tell you
in the track when I tell you it's big
what's one it's two it's only two
features on there okay two of the
biggest like and it's not the hype
biggest they actually like hard artists
like the biggest like like and they got
a lot of hype of course like you know
saying they get all that they got all
these flowers
not confirmed but but kind of confirmed
right he's on the album right well April
7 you know they ain't too far away I
feel like but one of them is like for
this time period like what's going on
everything going on it's going really
like the fans gonna appreciate this like
so much like and it's just like
everybody on there no no yes I feel like
it's going to spoil it a little bit but
everybody that's on there everybody
that's on there oh they've been on all
the other stream likes Jones but the
tracklist drop we're probably gonna try
that like next week on the floor it's
getting it's crunch time like
[__] damn April 1st no April Fools
it'd be crazy if post Malone was on the
album
maybe Wayne I don't know you might
personally play some April Fool uh
pranks on some people you know Sandra
around with everybody real quick on
Twitter how many songs are on the
project 12 12. I like that because I
feel like your guys's first album was
like very like tight easy digestible
yeah for sure like yeah okay putting
this one aside what's the best Rim life
it's a one or two it's got to be one or
two like the first one yeah and then no
type is my favorite record we ever did
person I record really changed those
lives yeah for real yeah just the way we
kicked in the door No Flex Zone was like
a Vibe but no tight yeah it was that's
the other deal that's still the one you
know what I'm saying
that just get hit like a new song like
when you're when you're performing and
everything what is the mixture for you
guys like when I mean obviously uh I
gotta give you credit because you're one
of the best songwriters of this
generation I appreciate it I don't know
I still play like the unforgettable
version that has your vocals in the
background
I never got like an updated version from
a DJ pool so if you ever hear your that
version on the radio yeah
velcro boys
I still have that red like like the
first version
yeah so for you uh when it comes to like
the pen game like how active are you
still for writing other artists like
writing for other artists rather right
now I just been in my own world so like
I just been complete my solo projects
completing this race room project you
know saying just keep my keeping active
just stay writing stuff like I just
write
and you never know where it's gonna go
like I might write a song five years it
might go to another artist you know what
I'm saying it might go to me I might
drop it myself like I just let
like features and stuff they just happen
organically with me like I might run
into an artist you know saying we sit
down we play some we see where the virus
go but do you like do the punching thing
or do you lay the melody first and then
go back and do the lyrics like what's
your process if I'm really just locked
in I already got some ideas on my head I
can just freestyle like swing that was a
freestyle lit like big that was a
freestyle like Unforgettable yeah I
wrote that like two bars at a time like
three bars at a time just float and just
piece it together and just like you know
saying just I just went with like a
climax and just like
emotional roller coaster
just up and down on that you wanna see
Jimmy
yeah I got the pre-rolls Buddy if you
want I don't like pre-rolled I ain't
gonna only lie to you I know that's like
the meal it's not mid it's like it's
like a shake it's like no no no no no no
no no these are the pre-rolls these are
like the guys Jordan
if you made them I'll smoke them but I
don't know
bro I'm saying the mid this ain't the
shake I need to roll one up man
oh damn
damn
let me know if you guys want to do some
we could do that uh they ain't gonna
kick in during the interview I already
took shots at the last one
they ain't gonna kick in during the
interview gonna be somewhere else
geeking geeked out
um
what about you Jimmy what's your writing
process like man like when you get in
the booth are you are you writing it
down are you punching in what's your
process you know I just want to like I
don't really want to speak on that right
now I want to wait till the album drop
because I feel like this album is gonna
be a
like like I said all our albums you can
see the growth in this and this one's
gonna be super
big growth you dig what I'm saying
because how do you feel like you grew
like the most from from this time that I
took off I grew in every single way like
but you know I'm gonna let my action
show that's why I'm at in my life right
now I feel like I'm in the show and
prove era you did what I'm saying and
that's what I'm doing and I'm going
crazy and I'm gonna keep doing that is
there a tour in the works boys yeah it's
a tour in the works are you guys
headlining you guys getting on someone
else's tour what's going on we're going
on tour with post Malone uh but yeah
we're doing Coachella after we come back
we're doing our own headline tour after
that yeah so you're going on tour with
post Malone yeah we're going to tour
post uh Europe tour of London yes
um like would make sense Germany to go
yeah it makes too much sense that's twin
man Shout Out Post Malone it would make
so much sense because he's on your
guys's album
it only makes sense that you guys go on
tour with them because he's one of the
two features on the contest yeah
[Laughter]
they got us man
am I right
start the countdown man you know what I
love is that you haven't said no start
the countdown man like if I said Ozzy
Osbourne's on the album you'd be like
nah that's crazy no
yeah
Ozzy might have some background vocals
on there too now are you guys still um
doing your Festival in your hometown
we're gonna bring like um yes we gotta
bring it back and just revamp it like
make it even bigger this time like if I
remember one year you guys had Wayne and
it was it would look crazy yeah it
jumped big it was just
definitely get when we revamp it because
we took the time off so it's like now we
come back we gotta make sure we're doing
it even bigger and better like and we
had coffee we had a lot of [__] yeah
exactly that's what I'm saying we come
back
a little bit of grovel oh yeah so that's
that's just that's just you know you're
just a grab a guy then just that's what
it is
there's even this right here there's a
little horse right here but I could do
this though you did what I'm saying I
just got the key fooling and stuff yeah
come out your face off for sure I see
them little strips right there the gas
ain't bad you guys at all
life I like it
I ain't gonna learn some crazy I was
actually like the other day I was just
thinking like shrimp life that could
like that could be one of our logos
because we ain't never really had a logo
yet bro one day bro it could be like two
you know we live in Miami bro one day I
was on the beach bruh
I don't know tell the story let's talk
about the craziest trips we've had so
bam I ate this chocolate so bam it's a
magic chocolate so bam I hate the
chocolate I'm chilling vibing then this
magical dude with long hair walks up and
then he got some so then he gives us
some real like not the ones on the
chocolate wait who it's a magical dude
with long hair I was already tripping so
I was lit so go down uh we taking shots
this is a real guy no this is a real God
it's really happening so bandana then I
got everybody was so hyped everybody was
so hyped didn't know nobody want to do
them so I'm like so you you did them
crazy time of the day is this it's like
two o'clock P.M two in the afternoon on
the beach in Miami random dude comes
through
and you ate all of them I ate all of
them so bad so we right down the street
from the SLS they got the crazy pool
party so bam
I'm walking as I'm walking the walk just
get better and better it's like the air
is just more air it's more air
everything's really HD it just got real
so country music like yeah I'm like wow
and then I get to the pool party and
then it's like it's too many people it's
like I could feel everybody walking by I
had to get out the party but I know
probably people looking at me weird I
was like
so bam
I go to my crib I start playing the game
I'm playing Elder rings I'm playing
Elder it's a game right there boys
looking too crazy so I had to turn it
off I started going through my phone all
the the words is popping out the screen
it's like hey I'm tripping so bad I was
like I don't went to sleep I go to sleep
my dreams is way too Vivid I wake up
like I'm just tripping the whole night
like it was the craziest day the
craziest thing is when you're tripping
hard and you try to go to sleep you
don't go to sleep you just dive into
like it's like rough
simulation then it went crazy so I woke
up the next day right I'm like man glad
that's over drinking water I'm going
through my day everything normal pull up
on this bad Crazy Fine pretty girl right
Tanisha you know we're gonna call her
right now
are we chilling she like oh I got the
best weed ever roll that up you know
what I'm saying we chilling Reviving she
let her I hit the blunt
the room just started getting smaller
it's like it just started leaning in I'm
like I gotta step outside so I stepped
outside so I stepped outside I feel
better I go back inside I'm tripping
again so now I call my friend I said bro
I need an Uber I need an Uber I don't
know why I couldn't call on my phone I
didn't even call it I need an Uber I'd
have ran to the to the uh to the tire
shop and I'm sitting in the front of the
tire shop waiting on the car these girls
was tripping they thought they did
something wrong they texting my phone
like is everything okay what did I do
did I say something yeah I didn't even
notice I didn't say nothing until I just
walked out and took off running I'm
walking I'm running down the street like
this
imagine you're getting your tire changed
you look over and Slim Jimmy from race
rumors just sitting there tripping balls
come back get an Uber man on the way
home like like I said I'm never doing
that again but like that was an eighth
of shoes and that was like the craziest
yeah you ate the whole eighth yeah yeah
that's a serious amount buddy that's
going yeah what about you what's the
worst trip you've had
man I ain't gonna lie I can't tell what
my worst experience but I can tell like
one of the things I like happened like
like
that you got to do like if you're
tripping like you just gotta like hang
on I looked in the mirror like one time
like after I came home or something I
just looked at myself in the mirror
like I was seeing myself like how
another person seen me or something like
you know what I'm saying like from
another person's eyesight like I was
like damn that's what I look like like
and it just like I just came to a
realization like like damn like that's
what girls see like when they look at me
and stuff like it was it was crazy
but this one time like we when I first
did them like when we first like like
shrimp like life like we was living in
Atlanta and stuff like me and Jay
actually didn't like my DJ right uh
right there
like random girls like they just like
liked our music we told them to go in
the studio like they came with us like
it was like two or three of them once we
were sitting on the couch like
boom we did like all of us did them like
when we recording and stuff like he was
where this actually yeah boom because he
was in the booth he started rapping
about some crazy deep stuff like nobody
loves me everybody today
life isn't probably honestly like don't
listen to that life isn't promised why
are we here I just want to be like I'm
like yo hey yo I'm on the show so then
everything started changing like boom
like so the girls they was next to me
they was looking like they started
asking me a question I'm trying to write
my verses I'm listening to the beat like
I'm focused still like even when she's
on a Vibe like then they start asking me
like why aren't you talking to us like
why aren't you showing me any attention
like well I'm like I'm just I've been
chilling like and they start asking in
my head I'm thinking I'm like and then
why they asked me like literally why
don't you love me like why don't you
love us like they don't do something
like I'm understanding like okay this is
crazy like so one thing to ask somebody
yeah they ask like why don't you love
them I'm like I love everybody like I'm
you know what I'm saying I'm like I'm a
down the Earth like but they kept just
like talking to me I had to just like
walk away and just like lay under the
piano and I was just like getting away
from everybody just laying on the piano
like Jesus what's worse though is it the
wheat Edibles or the because I think
this is a crazy story bro one time all
right that was one time I did by myself
when I over over did but one time I was
on a boat with sway we on the boat we're
in the middle of the ocean you need to
have me
we got 30 girls on the boat we in the
middle of the ocean it's a good
allegedly right right but right before I
take I'm in there dancing because I be
dancing so I'm in there like this you
know what I'm saying so then I take
I start crying bruh I don't know what
was wrong I don't went to the front of
the boat everybody like where's Jimmy at
where's Jimmy at farming the boat like
what's going on why was it I ain't never
even told somebody because I that
everybody thought they did something
wrong they ain't doing nothing wrong no
I was good I think I think I think I
think I was in tune with the universe or
something yeah it was crazy I've had
that happen where I've been at the club
and then I just looked at my boy I was
like bro I love you bro like you're my
brother I [__] love you like and I
started crying I'm like I want you to
know I appreciate you bro and he's like
what's wrong with you I'm like I just
love you dog like I appreciate your
friendship you know what I'm saying now
you want to compliment people now but if
you eat it's way worse it's way worse
you just I don't like it you don't know
how you don't know how that's gonna like
react to your like your body gonna react
to that like it could kick in you just
be super sluggish throwing up yeah like
it tastes good I'm gonna eat I'm gonna
eat it like some candy and then I'm
gonna be asleep for two days you guys
should do a whole album just a week in
the middle of like Costa Rica the whole
time it just called not for real mixtape
forever what's the best music to trip to
the best music dance speaking of Ozzy
Osbourne what's that one more time
oh yeah that's a good one that is a good
one you guys ever listen to Tame Impala
huh a Tame Impala on it hold on man I'm
gonna tell you better than that man this
time right here that's the one Ozzy
Osbourne song I got
oh oh what's that one song that one song
be lit I ain't gonna lie hey yo stop I'm
a rocket man this bootleg cab here gotta
stop the interview to tell you about our
good friends at King Palm now listen
guys all I do is smoke out of King Palm
if you see me smoking it's out of King
Palm all right and I'm gonna shout them
out because it's all natural
no tobacco to tobacco-free uh product
also no additives no need to split it
open no need to lick it comes ready to
go all you have to do
is put your uh your tree your flower of
choice right into here and you're good
to go now the best thing about King Palm
they have these turbine enough infused
wraps right here they're flavored uh
this is my favorite I do love watermelon
all right bursts of watermelon flavor
again no tobacco no additives all
natural all you got to do is pack it and
you aren't ready to go now this is
what's dope about King Palm if you go to
the website right now you know they're
the new sponsor I've been using them
forever so I had to hit them up like hey
guys I'm tired of smoking your guys's
[__] I'd love some support on the
podcast of course all right so go to
kingpom.com right now use the promo code
bootleg Kev and You're Gonna Save 50 off
um you can get whatever you need you can
order it online because these are
tobacco free no nicotine baby all right
so you can get it right to your house
half off kingpom.com keyword bootleg
heavy you can also hit your local
7-Eleven you could also hit your local
smoke shop one of the best selling
brands in America at the smoke shop so
many different products rollable wraps
hemp cones all the smoking accessories
one would ever need the smoothest smoke
the easiest to use
what are you [__] doing if you're
smoking and you're smoking at anything
but this you're [__] crazy all right
go check them out online socials one
more time kingpom.com promo code bootleg
save half off taking you on that natural
path King pong baby hey also shout out
to the homies at Blue chew man don't
forget if you're dealing with erectile
dysfunction if your penis is not
functioning correctly
it's a little flaccid you're trying to
get it a little hard a lot of hard
rather Bluetooth is where it's at a lot
of people ask me you always talk about
Bluetooth does it work yes it works all
right uh listen it has the same active
ingredient as Viagra and as Cialis but
it's in a chewable form all right it is
sent right to your door uh in a discrete
package it's a great thing man go to
bluetooth.com right now you use that
promo code bootleg right now you're
going to get a month supply for free of
Bluetooth why not have some better sex
okay seriously uh there's so many other
ways you can get down too because they
just dropped the Bluetooth mint flavor
which is the same active ingredient as
Levitra just so many things we can do
here uh and look when you go to
bluetooth.com and you sign up with that
promo code bootleg they're gonna
literally send it straight to your crib
for free five dollars in shipping you
get a month supply for free now how does
it work one you don't need to go to any
doctor's appointments it's all handled
online with an online pharmacist you
don't have to worry about going and
sitting in a waiting room to go discuss
your dick with some strange dude or
chick hmm maybe you're into that I don't
know with that being said it's an
awkward situation all right if you're
dealing with erectile dysfunction all
you need to do is go to bluetooth.com
right now use the promo code bootleg and
you'll get one month supply for free
zero dollars right to your door your
wife will even never know it even
happened you know what I'm saying maybe
you've been a little embarrassed you're
tired of piping down that same old bra
that you've been sleeping with for the
last 35 years put a little pep in your
step man take a Bluetooth use that promo
code bootleg bluetooth.com and try it
for free also got a shout out to my
bookie man Final Four Is On The Way NBA
playoffs are here well almost here we
got like a few games left right so much
going on you got the Masters coming up
man so many ways to win money
join us in my bookie I've been using my
bookie for about a decade now it's where
I put all my bets in uh there's so many
ways to win money with my bookie if you
go to my bookie right now you sign up
mybookie.ag promo code bootleg and you
will get double deposit bonus action
that means your very first deposit up to
a thousand dollars make that deposit
with that promo code bootleg when you
sign up for that new account and they're
going to give you uh uh another thousand
dollars they're gonna double your first
deposit so you might put 200 in you
might put 500 in they will give you
another 200 another 500 to gamble with
all right so much to do with my bookie
obviously we love betting on sports
literally one of my biggest passions in
life is gambling away my money and
winning money on mybookie.ag now I got a
few Futures going on right now I got
Joelle embed doing the MVP I got the
Phoenix Suns to win the West I got the
Bucks to win the East NCAA action I'm
taking UConn all the way what are y'all
doing go to my bookie right now they got
the props you can do the player props
you can do the over unders you can do
whatever you need plus live Blackjack
live roulette I have so much fun on my
bookie you really don't ever need to
leave your house
shout out to my booking mybookie.ag sign
up right now with the promo code bootleg
and get that first deposit bonus
what are we talking about who else is
going to double your first deposit
ladies and gentlemen mybookie.ag promo
code bootleg sign up and let's win some
money now let's get back to the
interview so both of y'all are in Miami
now yeah we both in Miami yet okay how
do you guys I mean I know you guys are
awesome he moved me to land because he
was down there having a good air time
every day and I was in Atlanta working
out working hard it is the thing that's
why I even like it's tax-free like so no
state tax exactly because you guys were
in L.A exactly so I was making a million
you know you making a lot of money but
it's you give them half your money to
Uncle Sam giving half your money to Joe
Biden for him to send that [__] over to
another country and you know what I'm
saying Joe Byron Joe Byron hey at least
Ukraine straight right young guy hey boy
oh God he got no straightforward he got
his own country straight like I don't
really if Trump spins the block are you
guys going to vote for Trump
if I had to choose between the A and A B
I definitely go with Trump over buying
for sure
I choose not to speak on politics you're
a smart man
I believe anybody would choose that
light though
I'm gonna just do a write-in if you know
I'm gonna probably just write in I'm
gonna write in Swae Lee yeah because bro
Trump [__] everybody [__] well he
had to eat here I mean listen
he free Little Wayne like he did Kodak
everyone tapped in more than buying them
I speak on the politics I'm gonna talk
facts like I ain't scripted I got points
behind my you know I'm saying my
politics I'm gonna speak on the point
I'm gonna have some facts to back it you
feel me so
if a [__] had the truth between hey bro
it's tapped in with with John Legend
though
come on man
I'm the Trump free Lil Wayne
and Kodak and Kodak Black and ASAP Rocky
come on man he actually tapped in like
he also normalized a lot of crazy but
you know that's neither here nor there
uh most he did
I ain't saying like if I ain't saying my
go-to guys neither one of them my go-to
guys but if I had to choose yeah if you
had to choose but if you was at home if
I had to choose if I only had two
options Joe Biden and Trump that's what
I'm saying let me clear it up because
you know how they get what
you know you could just hit him with the
heart neither
if they had if they asked me
the president of the United States can
either be Joe Biden or Donald Trump
right and those are my only options you
definitely want to party with Trump over
Biden that's for sure that's what I'm
saying he got a lot of he got a lot of
Pros more Pros than than your body you
feel me Joe Biden got more cons up like
Trump
um he on his business you know what I'm
saying yo whatever happened to your pet
monkey that Molly Maul gave you
by the way Molly Mall just got out yeah
free Molly no he's already out he's home
yeah yeah he um
I got the monkeys there well one of them
it was actually crazy because I didn't
have my USDA license so when I was on
tour yeah you gotta have a tour because
my monkey got famous in L.A my monkeys
was famous in L.A so everybody was
wearing on the street I swear they got
the monkeys right he had his party you
can go to his parties and you can see
the monkeys they run around drinking
alcohol with you jumping on girls
titties and [__] like you know what I'm
saying it's like they had a bad
reputation so well you had more than one
monkey I had two yeah I had two monkeys
I used to like when I raised them I used
to have one on their shoulder one on
their shoulder like in the studio boom
feed them they bottles like they
actually like ripped both of my ears
like my ears like sliced like my diamond
rings came out like they pulled my
diamond rings out damn like really
raising like little babies like diapers
like chain diapers like everything like
then what it was my first kids like but
yeah right now I'm working on getting a
USDA license you know where they at
though did you have to give them away
one of them they had kicked like my door
in my Mansion Dory when I was on tour
and they took like they ran in my house
and took my monkey like the the animal
control people I guess they were it's
like they kidnapped your kid literally
it was really illegal like and I really
need somebody to uh help me and give me
some assistance with that if you're
watching this interview you know how to
like get a monkey back yeah get the
monkey back because it was illegal some
illegal going on and they took my monkey
all right where's the other monkey the
other monkey is with my family members
in a very safe location yeah
allegedly dude money back yo had a pet
tiger in his backyard let's fly it's
exotic we Kings we supposed to live like
kings yo
this is a wow two monkeys one's gone one
is in a very undisclosed safe location
allegedly did your did your monkey ever
jerk off
um it got to the age before I lost it
where it started like discovering what
it's like private parts were so like and
it would like sometimes like grab the
[__] it didn't jerk up with it like my
girl Mike would like grab her be like
looking at it and just like oh it's a
girl Mark so like when I was uh it was
like 2010 I was at Mall's house and he
had his monkey bubs and his monkey had
you probably met bubs this is like he
had a wild monkey
so he had a portable DVD player in his
cage
and on the portable DVD player he was
watching a Curious George cartoon and he
was stroking his
while watching a cartoon monkey I swear
to God it was the first time I ever
brought two chains over to Molly Maul's
house this is like 2010 and we were
tripping out because we were watching a
monkey jerk off while watching a cartoon
monkey that monkey was Advanced bro
that's the next level turned to a human
you know how the monkeys evolve to
humans that one is close to evolving
into a human because
I think oh he was almost beat they meet
that's like a normal thing you want to
do is beat your meat my dog don't beat
it to me bro dogs be licking their meat
they be licking their meat yeah cause
they don't got hands so they gotta lick
their meat that's what make the next
level they turn on the movie
balls balls hey yo hey nah so my I have
a friendship he'd be sucking himself off
for sure pause yeah I mean you know
I guess if you could do it none of us
could do it we can't say hey yo
it ain't gay
no it's not no that's nice now I'll be
having a threesome with my hands
nighttime
what y'all's go-to category on the Hub
whoa hey yo the go-to category is it
BBWs
YouTube I'm saying I'll be bumping my
music in the morning Marvin Gaye okay
pause
me not before though what's your go-to
uh category
[__] I got my own personal archive oh
you got your you just you're just
digging through the memories I'm a
director myself
you know so you you only going off of
your own personal material I'm just
making quality material
are you ever afraid that kind of leak
I'll be hoping this the thing like no I
actually I need some sleep because I did
some goofy like angle I gotta I might
have to throw my meat on the internet
nah for real cause I feel like I was
trying to show my tattoo one time like
like a couple years back I just got a
tattoo on my stomach boom I was like in
the bathroom just making a video like
this boom
and I actually like you showed you yeah
it was like from a weird angle like from
the top and it wasn't it wasn't
flattering man it was like it's like it
was just like right in between like the
hoes like we can't tell if it's long or
short like
accidentally showed everybody your man
I'm in the Hills I'm in the Airbnb just
got the tattoo boom
boom look at that I'm trying to see what
it look like boom record it this one the
Instagram just changed but once I'm in
the bathroom I'm getting ready to go
somewhere I'm in the bathroom
I accidentally hit the it's a button
where you don't even it don't even ask
you do you want to post this yeah yeah
it just goes to your story right
okay boom I think that's my phone up I
actually hit that button boom so boom
upload to my story so I'm getting ready
still just trying to shower put my
clothes on the [__] on the [__] online
circular circulating online you know you
check your phone you're like oh [__] I'm
just doing my normal activities getting
dressed with my kids I'm going to the
car so it's like a 15 20 minute process
just me going from the bathroom to the
car driving around the hills you know
what I'm saying and no service on my
phone no idea what's happening no idea
was going underwear so Boom everybody
start hitting me sway yeah it's online
I'm like what like boom because I did
right before that though while I was
getting a tattoo I'm uploading all type
of [__] my drawers right here yeah you
can see it by my midsection yeah so I
was like look I was like oh they talking
about yeah because I did that make
session I did post purposely right so
then boom like what boom like stop
playing and watch my storyboard okay see
that boom cool boom still driving
somebody else hit me sway bro check your
Gram your meat is online I'm like what
the [__] boom I go I get like away from
my Airbnb I'm like going to the city now
so like this like 10 minutes later I had
to check my story and make sure there
was no meat on it
it's like 10 minutes later yeah it was
on there like but it was late at night
so boom I Knew by morning like man it
was everywhere yeah I knew it was gonna
be viral bottom so at that point if it's
an um unflattering angle do you say hit
one of the shortest and be like yo I'ma
need you to just like
you just gotta drop another
meat pick
no no no no for sure you gotta drop
another one you just gotta go back to
back like definitely one day I'm gonna
have to because like some people still
be like you know what I'm saying
sometimes trolling like you know hey
some people
and not showers
I'm a grower not a show I don't really
know either yeah I don't really know I
just I just know my situation and I
don't want to have it have you ever
accidentally leaked photos of yours no
but look I'm trying to figure out how to
accidentally do it
if anybody got any tips it's really easy
it's super easy what's the correct way
you know what I'm saying let's go
correct way
all the fans in it you can do yeah stay
off the only fans guys hey we gotta stop
the interview real quick to tell you
about our family at Odd Socks baby
that's right shout out to Odd Socks
little Godfather sock right there
craziest licenses in the game the most
comfortable socks period And if you go
to oddsocksofficial.com right now use
the promo code bootleg you're gonna get
20 off at checkout now they also got the
underwear going on these are some Street
Fighter draws pop these boys open
check them out
oh yeah oh yeah a little Chun Li versus
Blanco
what
amazing
do you like YooHoo so much that you'd
wear you who on your feet
there's people running around out here
with goddamn hot Cheeto jumpsuits right
now so of course you would shout out to
Yoo-hoo they got crazy licenses we
already mentioned Street Fighter
Coca-Cola Pepsi yes they got the they
got the boat there they got Pepsi and
Coca-Cola uh they also got Scarface
Breaking Bad WWE so many dope licenses
plus their Odd Socks Basics line which
are these just kind of the normal socks
in my opinion are the most comfortable
socks I've ever put on my feet I promise
you you gotta go to autotoxofficial.com
right now and use the promo code bootleg
save 20 off your entire order alright so
go do that
oddsoxofficial.com also want to give a
shout out to our family at hardean
that's right Jardin the craziest
dispenser you've ever walked into in
your life Harding Las Vegas you gotta
pull up follow them on Instagram Harding
underscore Las Vegas you see the Hat you
see the logo shout out to the family at
hardean if you're in Vegas you gotta
stop off you got to go pick you up some
weed it is legal in Vegas tell them I
sent you they're gonna take care of you
all right uh make sure you follow them
Harding underscore Las Vegas the largest
selection of previous cannabis I've ever
seen in my life the best smelling place
I've ever walked into in my life they
have a signature scent that's [__]
insane so shout out to hardine go follow
him Hardy underscore Las Vegas check out
more info about them at
jardinlasvegas.com let's get back to the
interview okay have you guys ever
subscribed to any any young ladies
content online just support you know
it's like I feel like it's kind of like
the new strip club you're supporting a
entrepreneur
I'm Gonna Keep it a bean I was the whole
Avenue was like I was curious one day I
did buy this one honest ladies only fans
you support it you supported her
entrepreneurship but guess what guess
what may guess what I would say honest
lady when I bought the only fans and
what number but cheerleading pictures
like this like
everybody the only fan they posting
videos right not getting a dime for it
you're not getting a cent for it you're
going only fans you posted might make
300 400 for it yeah you know what I'm
saying so it's like I get it like I
respect it's 2023 it's the social media
age like it it's a whole industry you
know I'm saying online Industries they
can you can really do good because like
think about it like me I'm so curious
yeah
because you'll see like a chick that you
know cheerleader football team you'll be
like I know this person and and it costs
ten dollars to see what their looks like
yeah I'm just curious like you got the
only thing they know that you know you
know this big one is only fans but you
don't have to do it for that it could be
for anything it's like if I did it it
would be fulfilling it was like gaming
you know what I'm saying like you could
like show people how to cook or yeah
now it's a lot of us yeah yeah a lot of
people doing it for whatever but you
know what I'm saying and I get it I get
it what cities got the better strip
clubs Atlanta or Miami you guys have
lived in both places
but you can get all the Vibes in Miami
you go to G5 you go to yeah it's a mixed
drink and then you go to school after
that after you go to that strip club you
might get on the boat after that John
you know it's just it's just crazy
Miami's like Grand Theft Auto it's just
it's like living in Vice City it's crazy
yeah what's your favorite Strip Club in
Miami
Club Club 11 for sure
are we counting that I know it is a
strip club but it feels more like a it's
a good egg look yeah just the history
when they treat us in there he's like
when you guys perform there a lot yeah
exactly exactly so that's where we all
know I love them that's what we always
be here it's a great place safe place
and gold rush I'll be a gold rush Gold
Rush okay I think golders got like a
nice selection of women like have you
guys ever gotten shoulder ropes or
tootsies
yeah yeah and it is everything they
hyped up to be
the the tootsies I think that a couple
different types of Roads
do you have to pay for them
I left a little nice tip yeah you know
what I'm saying like yeah tootsies is a
place where you know if you get if you
come in with the right money you're
gonna get Max love for sure I have a lot
of love for sure you can get a lot of
love when I go to strip club I was like
bro
a band that's just like
this right a thousand dollars you should
go on an agent with the money phone like
right off the rips what's the most
you've ever spent at a strip club the
most
I ain't gonna lie like when I'm in there
it's like I want to see how they
reacting to my music and stuff so
sometimes I just go in there and go nuts
like if I drop a new song I might just
but I ain't never went like way crazy I
ain't one of them like 100k 200k got
type Guys Five Ten Thousand something
like that
like 9 500 I just want a weird numbers
not even 10 bands 9 500. that's a
specific number nah for real for real 95
I'll be keeping up you know I keep up
with that with that ticket like uh you
can somehow we've never gotten the true
swaely solo album what's what's the
status with that buddy facts not fast
it's just like
you know I'm saying it's the whole
agenda going on so it's like
race trimmer that's like main focus 24a
like that's the main focus but now I
think it's like now that everything in
overdrive like this year and just like
now that I know the direction I really
just want to go my music like I always
knew I wanted to go up he just wouldn't
leak the meat pick
drink a lot of water
I mean are we good
all right okay but not yet yeah
definitely this year like and I ain't
just gonna say one solo project just
like which albums on albums you know
saying shrimp life might drop a couple
projects true for sure shroom life
shroom life yeah we come with them back
to back tour with post Malone
solo tour
I feel like yeah
we all just
and you definitely on this album is like
it's real interest like you're gonna get
a sample of both of us by itself of
course you it's not you know what I'm
saying people don't I'm excited for it I
don't want to give though
hands about the album it's gonna be a
good album so it comes out April 7th
April now we're getting we're getting I
feel what you're saying he's saying
you're getting some gym Slim Jimmy hooks
like big Slim Jimmy hooks right you know
what I'm saying like on the early one
it's like boom
I might have been on the majority of the
hooks like people now they're getting to
understand Slim Jimmy even more in the
boom understand what he brings to the
table understand what I bring to the
table like you can hear him on the
standout songs you can hear me on some
standout songs and it's just like in
here post Malone on the song
Love posty
my job a little verse you know what I'm
saying ah I might just
couldn't or is that a soft confirmation
it's a soft confirmation obviously
so the confirmation wasn't going to be a
hard one it was going to be a soft one
hey yo whoa that was a good one though
hey that was a good one that was fine
ladies no we got the hard proof though
for you the hard proof for the ladies
are both you guys single right now
is it is it complicated what's going on
I mean I got some big news I'm probably
gonna as soon as this interview come out
man I'm announced the big news man okay
I don't know if the world ready man for
this one
Jesus I'm about to sing something crazy
you're single and he's gonna announce
that he's I don't know I don't know I'm
single as a pringle ready to mingle but
got down you know what I'm saying right
now I'm in a serious relationship with
myself so I'm not even trying to do that
manual stimulation is what it's all
about
um
there it is guys well I appreciate y'all
April 7th the new album is out it's out
right now follow us up shrimp like foe
man sure like full show for Life shout
out to all the stands shout out to
shrimp like day ones yes sir boom